over the years Greek mythology has given
us a host of monsters and creatures
along with their origin stories but one
of the lesser well-known stories is that
of King Lycaon and the legend of the
first werewolf Lycaon was the son of
Peleus one of the first mortals to walk
on earth there are quite a few variant
accounts on how Pulaski scam to exist
some believe he was born of the soil and
others believed that he was one of the
first mortal sons of Zeus like haein
would succeed his father and become the
king of the region that we now refer to
as Arcadia over time he had become very
famous because of his vast array of
wives two of which even included NIMS
naturally with so many wives came an
abundance of children it's generally
believed that Lycaon was father to over
50 sons the exact number of sons does
tend to vary depending on the source
material like haiyan's sons would travel
across the kingdom found in many of the
cities in Arcadia the downfall of lycaon
is a well-documented event that is quite
often split into several different
stories one of the stories told depicts
like Cain as a righteous king who
established his own City and even named
the mountain after himself he was
particularly fond of the Lycaon games
and he even constructed a temple in the
name of Zeus to honor him during the
games
it was the method that Lycaon used in
his worship of Zeus that was most
disturbing he would often sacrifice a
child upon the altar of Zeus the act of
human sacrifice especially that of a
child was something that Zeus would not
tolerate and as a result he rained down
bolts of lightning killing Lycaon and
his sons the more commonly told story is
what many believed to be the origin of
the werewolf legend in this version like
Cain was seen as a mischievous and
slightly deceitful king
in order to test Lycaon Zeus disguised
himself as a common laborer and visited
his kingdom so he could judge firsthand
what type of King like haein was as zeus
wandered through the kingdom his
divinity started to become apparent and
people began worshipping the stranger
like haein unaware of which deity it was
visiting his kingdom decided that he
would test the stranger he arranged for
a large banquet that he invited the
stranger to he then sacrificed the child
whose body pots were boiled and roasted
in preparation for the main course in
some cases it was a random child that
was sacrificed and in other versions it
was one of like haiyan's own sons when
the meal was served zeus revealed his
true identity and in his anger he
overturned the table and just as in the
last story zu struck down like a n' and
his sons now there are a handful of
different ways that this story ends some
believed that zeus only struck down like
haiyan's children and whilst this was
happening he attempted to flee zeus then
transformed him into a half wolf half
human creature and thus the legend of
the werewolf began the son that like
Haiyan had sacrificed Nick Thomas the
youngest of all of his sons was
resurrected by the gods and in most
cases he would become like a and
successor and the new king of Arcadia
the story of lycaon is quite an
intriguing tale
unlike most kings and mortals he did not
seem to fear the gods and this could be
partly to do with the fact that he
believes himself to be above mortals and
even a God of sorts himself it was this
disregard that led him to believe that
he could feed a god one of his own
children with no repercussions
ultimately his actions led to him being
cursed if he was to act like an animal
then in turn he will become one
hopefully you guys enjoyed the story if
you did let me know what you thought in
the comments below if werewolves are
something that interest you then I do
have an in-depth video on the origins of
the werewolf legend and how its evolved
over the years
there'll be an end screen that you guys
can click on and I'll leave a link in
the description but as always I've been
your host mythology in fiction explained